she is the first author to become a
billionaire
there are not many authors who keep
putting out books in a series that can
sell 10 12 15 million copies on the
first day of publication
her imagination has resonated with
children and adults and changed every
industry it touched harry potter itself
was as big as as a small publishing
company
harry potter is the gold standard it is
the biggest movie franchise of all time
but jk rowling's fairy tale success was
born out of struggle and heartbreak i
was jobless
a lone parent i was the biggest failure
i knew
with a storybook ending
chapter 1
at the center of the most financially
successful story in the history of
fiction harry potter is the original and
determined joanne rowling
she sold something like 400 million
copies of the series books in the united
states and she got a billion kids
reading
four five six hundred page poems uh in
an era where kids were not reading books
at all
probably over ten billion dollars in
overall revenue generated this is an
absolute
amazing
franchise that i think we won't see
again
harry potter's popularity thrust rolling
into the unfamiliar world of celebrity
after being hounded by paparazzi she now
limits access to her private life and
declined to participate in this story
joanne rowling was born in 1965 and
gloucestershire england
actor jim dale rowling's choice of
narrator for the harry potter audio
books in the united states knew those
rural villages well
there were no rich people living in in
those small towns everybody was working
class you would go into the houses and
see the same wallpaper that you had
because there was only one wallpaper
shop in the town there was only one
co-op store and so you'd see the same
dress that your mother was wearing was
being worn by two or three other women
so it's that kind of environment
rowling's literary ambitions were
recognized at an early age she completed
her first book named rabbit when she was
six
melissa annelli interviewed rowling for
her book harry a history it was about a
rabbit who gets sick and is with all his
other animal bunnies and apparently when
she when she finished it she brought it
up to her mother and said and sort of
had this attitude of well publish it
doesn't it get made a book now you know
but underneath the confidence was
insecurity as rowling admitted on oprah
i was not the world's most secure person
um
i wasn't someone with an enormous amount
in fact i'd say i was someone with not
much self belief at all and yet in this
one thing in my life
i believed that was the one thing in my
life i felt i can tell a story
her story was shaped in tuscal a small
village in gloucestershire county
tanya sagachien worked closely with
rowling as a producer on the first four
harry potter films
she had both a microscopic and a
microcosmic view of hogwarts in the
harry potter universe she'd grown up in
the west country near the forrester dean
where i'd spend a lot of my childhood so
lots of points of reference that we had
in common
everything jk wrote about in her books
you know is a description of something
somewhere in england it has to be we do
have the fantastic old castles we do
have those wonderful ancient buildings
we do have those woods you can recognize
almost by her description of a place
that you know of
or somewhere around the area where she
lived
in 1980 her mother was diagnosed with
multiple sclerosis a tragic event for
the family
but it didn't divert rowling from her
passion for fiction in school or later
in college
joe was a classics major at exeter so
everything comes from there her
classical education is
all over the harry potter books the
greek myths the christian allegories
after college rowling paid her rent by
working at amnesty international in
london
writing stories on her lunch hour
then in 1990 on a train to london she
had an idea that would change her life
the train stall and literally into her
head came boy wizard doesn't know he's a
wizard goes to wizard school
and because she didn't have a pen she
had to sit and just think for hours and
while this train was stalled and it all
started she started naming the school
she started thinking of the teachers all
that sort of started forming in harry
potter and me she explains what a
life-altering moment this was that
incredibly elated feeling you get when
you've just met someone with whom you
might eventually fall in love
the whole of the harry world was her
passion the extent to which this
encyclopedic vivid mind knew what was
going to be behind a door that you
didn't even know existed it was amazing
really only six months later she
received heartbreaking news
her mother had passed away from multiple
sclerosis
rowling opened up about her loss for the
bbc
i started writing harry six months
before she died
which is uh
that's obviously a real regret
because i never told her i was even
writing it so she never knew anything
about harry potter at all
[Music]
joe's mother's death affected everything
about her writing every every last page
of harry potter it changed her views on
love and death and what it means when
somebody leaves us and the effect it has
on our lives
her focus on the boy wizard intensified
and she was eventually fired from
several jobs for writing instead of
working
it was a bleak time for the unemployed
author
rowling decided to leave england all
together
joanne rowling left england to make a
fresh start in porto portugal
she got a job as a teacher while she
continued writing
rowling married a local tv journalist
and within a year had a daughter
but after what she described as a short
and catastrophic marriage
she moved to edinburgh scotland to be
near her sister
i think she felt a bit of a failure
because she was poor because she was
very well educated but hadn't found
a positive career yet
she tried to get teaching jobs and work
was
not consistent and so she had to go on
on public assistance
it was hand to mouth day to day the
absolute subsistence level poverty it's
not glamorous and it's not romantic but
it did help
drive that book into production
rowling said that rock bottom became the
solid foundation to rebuild her life
and she continued to write in the warmth
of a cafe while her daughter napped by
her side
and when she had first three chapters
that she thought that she was happy with
she sent it off to an agent
it was rejected
in 1995 she sent three chapters to the
chris little agency
there it got the usual treatment for an
unknown author as little noted on 60
minutes
these things can sit in a pile for ages
you know because they're known as the
slush pile and just by chance
two days afterwards picked up this pile
and went off to a lunch because somebody
was turning up late and inside i started
reading about harry potter and you know
my toes my toes killed
but 12 publishers turned it down
nobody wanted it because at the time it
was very non-politically correct to have
boarding schools it was two times as
long as any children's book had a right
to be it had this onerous title harry
potter and the philosopher's stone you
know it was all the things that
publishing at the time
said they said books said books
shouldn't be
and so
he couldn't sell it
the book finally found its way to a new
children's imprint called bloomsbury
porter bib is a media analyst and former
publisher the ceo's daughter who read
the first
two chapters and came back to her father
and said she wanted to read more that's
part of the beauty of the book
publishing business it goes to a great
extent on gut feeling
in 1996 six years after she began
writing harry potter bloomsbury offered
her four thousand dollars for the book
it wasn't much as deals go but for
rowling it was magic
that moment when he told me that
bloomsbury wanted to take the book
second only to the birth of my daughter
was the happiest moment of my life
[Music]
but there was a catch
to try and improve its marketability
bloomsbury wanted her to change her pen
name to something gender neutral as
little pointed out on 60 minutes
traditionally boys don't like to read
books written by by girls girls read
books written by anybody but girl boys
have this sort of peculiar sort of
sexist thing
joanne borrowed a middle initial from
her grandmother kathleen and became jk
rowling
at the 1997 bologna book fair word of
mouth was building arthur a levine vice
president of scholastic had flown there
looking for something special
i wanted to find books that were not
just trendy or
um you know popular of the moment but
that
would be
really loved by kids and would be their
favorite books
michael jacobs was the senior vp of
scholastic's trade division at the time
this certainly was a book that was had
but had a lot of buzz going around at
bologna and i think yes it was pretty
evident i think to arthur that the book
had potential to be a series but the
first book itself was
extraordinary just as a standalone
levine offered an unprecedented 105
thousand dollars for american rights to
the first harry potter book
when joe got the call from christopher
little that said you know your book's
been sold for 105 000 in america she
said that she was very
um scared for the first time it was very
overwhelming
to be honest life had battered me around
so much in the previous few years that
when you start receiving good news
you're quite mistrustful
the good news continued
in 1997 the book was published in the uk
and it was a hit
[Music]
the first round of schoolyard
potterheads was born
joanne rowling's second book was already
in the works after the top dollar sale
of the first harry potter to scholastic
she felt enormous pressure to continue
the momentum
after the american sale it was a big
story in england because now an unknown
british author has sold their first book
in america which is the you know holy
grail as opposed to the english market
it's five or six times bigger
it was penniless author rags to riches
tale
the u.s publishers were hoping harry
potter would strike a literary goal
we knew we had something special on our
hands
you know you have a
sort of lightning in a bottle at a
certain point in time and we knew that
fairly early on so our approach really
was to publish it as a blockbuster
we had basically a kind of a swat team
war room at scholastic that met every
week about harry potter scholastic
decided to take an interactive approach
to marketing the book we did bats
reading copies of the book for a select
number of people got it into their hands
i think some of them actually got to
meet joe rowling before the book was
even published so you know we created a
buzz that way
but then once the book began to sell it
uh you know it just sort of took off
like wildfire
harry potter and the sorcerer's stone
sold over 800 000 copies in ten months
and spent more than a year on the new
york times bestseller list
as the second installment hit united
states stores in 1999 release of the
potter books became major events
scholastic cast a spell on the public
they put on extravaganzas with each new
title that came out and had literally
thousands of kids standing outside of
bookstores mostly in costume in the
middle of the night waiting to get the
copies
the logistics of laying
10 million or 11 million copies of a
book down on one day were uh were
difficult as you can well imagine in
transporting the books making sure they
were secure and locked down making sure
that books didn't get into anybody's
hands before they got in everyone's
hands
the sales on each book be sort of became
exponentially higher the first printings
became much much bigger
the one dark cloud that cast a shadow on
the growing phenomenon were protests
from conservative religious groups who
saw evil in the mystical storylines
they accused rowling of promoting
witchcraft and the occult and burned her
books
[Music]
even though harry potter has just taken
the world by storm witchcraft is not
fictional and it is not
fantasy witchcraft is real the devil is
real
if people think that witchcraft should
not be in books for children per se then
there's really no point in engaging in
the debate because a lot of classic
children's books are going to be right
off the library shelves
in an instant the wizard of oz
even cardinal joseph ratzinger now pope
benedict the 16th had his own
reservations
and the american library association
listed rowling's as the number one most
challenged text in the united states
but the backlash didn't affect sales at
all
harry potter's continual reign over the
new york times best seller list
ultimately forced the paper to add a
whole separate children's category i'm
sure our competitors were happier that
they may have been more slots in the
bestsellers because we were probably
would have dominated the top five with
the first five books and blocked
everyone else out
even audiobook sales were breaking
records and enchanting fans as narrator
jim dale discovered at a live reading in
new york
a count of 400 children and mothers
turned up and one child suddenly yelled
out you've left a sentence out as if it
was the biggest mistake and the mother
said i do apologize but
he's memorized the whole book
and from the audience i heard other
little voices calling out so have i so
have i
international distributors snatched up
the rights to translate the books and
harry potter became a worldwide
sensation
[Music]
demand became so intense that there was
a danger of the harry potter brand
spiraling out of control
we had supermarkets and convenience
stores and gas stations and sort of
other retailers whose all of a sudden
wanted harry potter books so that they
could drive traffic almost as a loss
leader for their particular business
jk rowling turned down hundreds of
licensing offers from the likes of sony
microsoft and boeing
but remained fiercely loyal to her
vision as she shared here on 60 minutes
if people could see the kind of offers
i've had to use harry and advertising
and
publicity and all sorts of
ridiculous frankly things and i've said
no to absolutely all of them
but there was one offer she couldn't
refuse from hollywood
and one studio was about to discover
that harry potter might just work
miracles
i was working for a new production
company for david hayman who said to me
go and find me something for the studio
well i read an article in a newspaper
that said that someone had written the
first in a seven series book about a
little boy who goes to boarding school
and discovers he's a wizard so when i
went and met her agent and tried to
convince him to let us buy it we were
coming as warner brothers
hall de garabedian is president of the
box office division of hollywood.com
i think for warner brothers to get the
harry potter franchise was a mission i
mean warner brothers had had great
success with the batman franchise with
the matrix franchise and i think they
were determined to do it and i think
that's why they gave jk rowling such
latitude in terms of her control over
this process and over the series of
films
our first meeting the jk rowling was
over lunch actually david hayman and i
had told her a little bit about what we
wanted to do with the film and she sat
down with us and we tried desperately
hard to impress her and
she of course didn't need to impress us
because she already had done
jk rowling was paid reportedly two
million dollars by warner brothers for
the rights to those first four films
there are not many authors who keep
putting out books in a series that can
sell 10 12 15 million copies on the
first day of publication that gave her a
lot of leverage
that leverage allowed her to demand that
the film be shot in britain with an
all-british cast
and that she would have a role in
choosing both the actors and
directors top directors clamored for
admission to rowling's imaginary world
well i know that steven spielberg was
approached to direct the first harry
potter film and he actually wanted to do
it as an animated film but that didn't
come to pass and so chris columbus
stepped in
producer david heyman introduced the
hand-picked cast in a warner brothers
video chris's choice of three wonderful
british actors for the leading roles
shows how well he understands the spirit
of these books i think her primary
concern about a film being made of her
vision was that we were true and
faithful to the books i think she had
really worked incredibly hard in
constructing characters in a story that
she believed in and what she didn't want
to see was that being chopped up and
misinterpreted one two three action
the biggest challenge of bringing jk
rowling's vision to the screen was that
by the time we were filming it everybody
had read it
[Music]
could you ever imagine that it would be
like this no never in a million years i
mean this was the last thing i expected
the first harry potter film hit movie
screens in november 2001 once again the
boy wizard worked wonders the film was a
record-breaking hit
it opened 90.3 million dollars which
turned out to be the biggest opening
weekend of that year the film went on to
earn 317 million dollars which was the
biggest earner domestically at the box
office in 2001
rowley not only retained creative
control she negotiated an undisclosed
percentage of the movie and licensing
profits more important she was happy
with the final product
i guess my abiding memory of her
reaction to the completed films was
we did it
it's all right we didn't let her down
2001 was also the year joanne rowling
happily married her second husband dr
neil michael murray
and the harry potter movies continue to
be blockbusters
every harry potter movie has opened at
number one it has a perfect opening
weekend track record we're talking about
a decade we're talking about seven films
the theatrical box office for the seven
harry potter films and this doesn't even
include
part two of deathly hallows is 6.4
billion dollars that doesn't even
include home video product tie-ins any
kind of soundtrack sales anything else
it's the biggest movie franchise of all
time
[Music]
rolling also receives a cut of mattel's
200 million dollar plus revenues in
harry potter toys and her merchandising
empire continues to expand
[Music]
it's hard to think of something that
didn't at one point or another have a
harry potter image attached to it
whether it's in the games business
toys even
clothing business it's humongously
successful
[Music]
in 2010 harry potter took claim of its
own theme park at universal studios in
orlando named the wizarding world of
harry potter
and once again rowling's personal stamp
was on everything from the snow on the
roof to the taste of the butter beer
they actually packed up the ingredients
went up to edinburgh made it and
presented it to her and she tasted them
all and said that one that one is
exactly butter beer
she's had two more children and now
makes her home on a pastoral estate in
northern scotland
and five years after the last potter
book rowling published a new novel for
adults
i have gone from
dragons and unicorns and all the fun
that's involved in writing that to
a book that's
intensely personal
that expresses
a lot of
my reality
the casual vacancy didn't have the same
magic with critics but it still hit
number one on the best sellers lists
rowling has redefined success in the
literary world
her net worth is estimated to be near
one billion dollars making her among the
richest women in the world
[Music]
she has become a wonderfully elevated
brand in terms of stature and ethics and
the way that she conducts herself her
generosity extends to charities that
include aid to single parent children
the poor and to multiple sclerosis
research
for 17 years rowling lived and breathed
harry potter her story much like his was
marked by overcoming dreadful challenges
on the way to extraordinary success
as she told the harvard graduating class
in 2008
the knowledge that you have emerged
wiser and stronger from setbacks means
that you are ever after
secure in your ability to survive
you will never truly know yourself
or the strength of your relationships
until both have been tested by
adversity such knowledge is a true gift
for all that it is painfully won
and it has been worth more than any
qualification i ever earned
[Music]
he was just another street hustler
now he's a ceo in command of a 450
million dollar global empire i don't
think that jay-z ever was just a
musician it was i'm gonna build jay-z
the corporation
no one ever suspected that you would get
this far and he would own clubs and
clothing lines and everything else that
he has its finger in he has boasted
about moving beyond the boundaries of
music and succeeded
jay
did not cross over to the mainstream he
took all the mainstream and bought them
a ticket to his world
he escaped the dark path taken by so
many others it happens all the time in
the projects you know you're having a
certain life and it needs no it leads
either to jail or leads to death
his survival skills and showmanship
launched him on a journey of a lifetime
he went from the street corner to the
corner office as a ceo that's what makes
him a game-changer jay-z is
a brilliant lyricist
he's a ruthless businessman
and he's a deal maker
that any major corporation would be very
fortunate to have sitting as its head
jay-z had this gradual but very profound
evolution from street corner hustler to
ceo to this phenomenal force in hip-hop
instead of just being one of he set
himself to be the one and that is just
an extraordinary feat to say i'm v1 not
one up but i'm v1
[Music]
that's him the awkward boy in the
classic portrait
sean corey carter who became the mega
star jay-z
jay-z was unavailable to participate in
this program
born in brooklyn new york on december
4th 1969
sean carter was the youngest of four
children
author jake brown he came out of hell i
mean he came out of a literal war zone
for what marcy projects was back in the
1980s it the fact that he survived that
being in the game as credibly as he was
is
is singular in my opinion fellow rapper
and early mentor jazzo lived in the same
housing project we did deal with a lot
of violence
you know a lot of
murder drug dealing uh drug abuse
poverty
was fortunate for some of us to be able
to come out of it
but many people that we knew never made
it his music hinted at his troubled past
but he rarely talked about it his candid
one-hour interview with charlie rose in
2007 was an exception the things that's
happened in these neighborhoods and one
day people
may have never experienced in their
whole entire lives i took a glimpse at
that life what what could have happened
to me had i stayed in the street you're
gambling you're playing russian roulette
with your life every single day 365 days
of the year you're gonna crap out sooner
or later it's just natural that's what
happens
there was always a funeral
somebody was being killed renee
rosenblum louden was jay-z's sixth grade
teacher
those kids went to sleep with gunshots
when these kids would come into my
classroom a lot of them would be
dozing
and i would let them
because i knew that they were up
up half the night
she never forgot the young sean corey
carter he was shy
and extremely bright
he was off the charts in in reading he
obviously had this innate ability he
later rapped about getting good grades
but that he had demons deep inside that
would raise when confronted he really
smiled and and i don't know if it was
sadness or just his personality but he
was always kind of laid back and not
smiling
when jay-z was 11 his father abandoned
the family in a rap called december 4th
his birthday he wrote he was a kid torn
apart
music journalist zach o'malley greenberg
i think that's something that made jay-z
sort of cold and and isolated you know
he was he was very hurt and something i
think that that led him to be the sort
of cold calculating businessman that he
is today
unsentimental
his lyrics reflected detachment and at
times rage
jay-z says in his own songs he shot his
brother in the shoulder for stealing a
piece of his jewelry
money was tight for jay-z's single
working mother
and there were few jobs for a teenager
in the projects
but with hustling and dealing drugs the
easy money flowed
dj mr c is a leading new york dj it was
about having
cash at large sums
at a quick amount of time and didn't
have to answer to nobody he basically
went about making money however he could
and
when he was young you know that was on
the street that was a selling crack
barry michael cooper is a journalist and
filmmaker here's a strange thing his
crack dealing
taught him
the you know value of being entrepreneur
of trying to take that notion of
people's needs and wants and filling a
niche to the world of records his love
for the world of records started at home
his mother having what he's talked about
being this record collection that was
sort of locally legendary to the project
and that everybody would come over to
their place to listen to music
in terms of his musical genius jay-z has
an encyclopedic knowledge of all kinds
of musical styles it's not just hip-hop
you know marvin gaye curtis mayfield
barry white
james brown of course but it's also rock
and roll you know the stones
[Music]
he had no formal musical training but
jay-z felt instinctively that rap could
be his way out of the projects
he didn't just listen he wrote lyrics on
napkins paper bags it poured out of him
he has said that he can store seven or
eight new songs in his head at a time
that really says something about the
amount of data that he can process at
any given time jay-z was more of a very
fast-paced rapper just taking the
stylist making the money to get a dick
dick jams you know what i'm talking
about or why i'm going too fast but he
also had melody to his rap which made it
very unique to what was out at the time
and i believed in him from day one he
was 15 years old so we rhymed and from
that point we vibed because
i heard him like he had pure talent you
know it's just raw talent jazzo was the
first rapper signed by emi records
in 1988 they sent him to london to
record word to the jazz he took 18 year
old jay-z along and featured him on this
song
the album did not break out and jay-z
went right back to the old neighborhood
jay-z's short experience with recording
industry was a disappointment
but his travels outside the projects had
opened his eyes to a much bigger world
he was focused enough to
say you know what i can't do this
forever i can't be a drug dealer forever
because there's only two ways it's gonna
end either you're gonna die or be in
jail you know and it was good thing i
had great people around me where i had
you know that fork in the road being
entertained or stay in the street you
know i chose to be an entertainer it
worked out for me and you know once i
took that right turn that you know to to
be an entertainer i never looked back
he made his name in a different kind of
street battle
they're just rap battling the street it
was more like
hand-to-hand combat street battles
acapella
just going at each other and that's how
kind of like jay made his mark do
through the street battles and it was
just like who is this guy and from there
it just the buzz kind of
started um happening from there
he performed for years at local parties
and clubs but couldn't get a record deal
frustrated he took a different route
i was forced to be an executive from the
beginning because when i tried to get a
deal in the beginning i couldn't get a
deal i went to every single record label
and i couldn't get the deal so it was
either give up and go back to the
streets or you know create our own
avenue and lane to uh
you know be heard
in 1994 jay-z met damon dash who is just
starting in artist management
at the time dash was a young
entrepreneur mostly focused on party
promotion he was managing a couple acts
as well
[Music]
damon dash saw gold in 24 year old jay-z
in 1994 they created their own label
rockefeller records with a third partner
corrine biggs burke
they pressed their own cds they promoted
they did everything stickers on club
doors they went around the city selling
these cds out of the back of their car
by 1995 everybody in new york knew
anything about hip-hop
knew who jay-z was
rockefeller did it their way they
finance their own videos they financed a
lot of their tours because they knew the
more money they spent
on their own they would keep for
themselves it was their profits
from the very beginning that was his
aspiration you know to
run his business which was rockefeller
like a corporate entity
[Music]
rockefeller self-released jay-z's debut
album reasonable doubt
the fledgling executive sold just over
500 000 cds in three months giving them
a solid platform for growth
it turned out that they were so good at
what they were doing and they were so
good at the promotion and jay-z's music
was so good which is the most important
part uh that it really took off and it
became this huge underground sensation
the hit album reasonable doubt also
featured new york's most popular rapper
jay-z's high school classmate
christopher wallace aka notorious b.i.g
the two brooklyn rappers often performed
together until the night of march 9th
1997
that was the night notorious was gunned
down in los angeles by an unknown
assailant
jay-z was shattered but it was also the
moment he became the most prominent
rapper in the country
he was very saddened by it because it's
very close to him but at the same time
he knew it was a prime opportunity to
fill that void that people were looking
for that real street voice with the
intelligence
jay-z's growing reputation attracted the
attention of music industry heavy
hitters russell simmons and leor cohn
and their def jam records label
i wanted rockefeller and the def jam
family simply because
i had this infrastructure
and
i needed
superb
and insanely creative people to take
advantage of that infrastructure
in 1997 def jam acquired 50 of
rockefeller records for 1.5 million
dollars
it was a partnership to run rockefeller
as a 50 50 joint venture it gave them
the corporate backing that they needed
to really kind of take it to the next
level and it gave them an equity stake
and that's what jay-z is all about
equity if you look through all this
business deals he always gets something
that he can hold on to
then came a rare misstep for the
supremely confident jay-z the album in
my lifetime volume
[Music]
one think the problem with in my
lifetime was it wasn't a very good album
jay-z really softened his sound in an
attempt to appeal to a wider audience
suddenly jay-z's career and street
credibility took a hit with his hardcore
fans
he said it was the album that got away
he needed a turnaround and that sent him
back to his troubled past
i don't know how to sleep i gotta eat
tart not life was uh
i mean that album was that was his
thriller
that was his michael jackson thriller
album
that was his first crossover hit um and
to think to take the annie theme
you know and put it in the context of
marcy projects is pretty brilliant and
it worked it was it was a it was a big
payoff it doesn't hurt that he has an
insane work ethic he worked really
really hard on creating it and and
promoting it and it paid off hard knock
life earned jay-z a grammy in 1999 for
best rap album jay-z the superstar had
arrived
it's so many things that make a time
where
one comes from
obscurity to celebrity
and i think that he was ready
the company was ready
and the fans were ready
the 54 city tour for hard knock life
grossed 18 million dollars album sales
hit 5 million
at the end of 1999 jay-z and his partner
started a clothing label in 18 months
rockaware generated 80 million dollars
in sales
he modeled himself after someone like a
t boom pickens or donald trump so to
speak at the end of the day it was about
having a house somewhere in the hamptons
you know and driving uh maybach which he
actually wound up doing you know what i
mean
whatever the comforts of success may
have brought him it didn't bring him
peace his temper suddenly and violently
resurfaced you know it was something
that
shouldn't happen
and he'll be the first one to tell you
that it was a bad mistake on his part
by 29 jay-z was a hip-hop superstar and
head of his own multi-million dollar
company he had spent years cultivating
his image
but on december 1st 1999 this most
calculating of men acted rashly stabbing
record executive lance on rivera at the
kitkat club in new york
lanceon rivero someone who jay knew well
trusted
found out
that
allegedly there was some bootlegging
going on and put a three-inch blade into
his stomach because he warned him to
stop and he didn't
this isn't a room full of witnesses
when he's got everything in the world to
lose
jay-z was charged with second-degree
felony assault he pled guilty and
received three years probation and no
jail time
he nearly messed everything up but he
came away with it looking like he was
the teflon rapper
the teflon rapper then met his diamond
diva beyonce knowles
for years they coyly avoided discussing
their relationship
it took a long time for him to come out
and publicly acknowledge that
relationship which i think shows you how
fraid he was of acknowledging how real
it was and that's something that just
that all that teflon that that had to be
stripped away and that trust that had to
be rebuilt she's the woman that that
kind of accomplished the impossible in
that respect
while his personal life was finally
settling down his business life was
taking off with more hits and awards
and by the end of 2001 his rock aware
clothing line was grossing over 100
million dollars in sales
a year later jay-z set another precedent
in a headline grabbing deal with reebok
steve stout of translation advertising
there was never a non-athlete that had
ever struck a major footwear deal with
one of the top three brands either nike
adidas or reebok and we sold 10 000
pairs of the sneaker within the first
hour and we went on to build a hundred
million dollar franchise off the escort
name
everything he touched seemed to catch
fire
he added a spark to beyonce's solo
career when he appeared in her breakout
single crazy in love
as her album took off he shocked his
fans and at the top of his game
announced his retirement from music you
know i'm happy with what i've
accomplished as a solo solo artist like
i feel like what else can i accomplish
i think he really
wanted to step away from the game for a
minute he felt that he had done all he
could do but here's the other thing i
think he wanted to see how people would
react to it if i say that i'm going to
retire jay-z you know the greatest
rapper living right now how would people
respond to that
his november 2003 farewell concert fade
to black at madison square garden sold
out in one day
the boardroom would become his new stage
in 2004 def jam bought the remaining 50
percent stake of rockefeller from jay z
and his partners for 10 million dollars
they announced that jay-z would become
president and ceo of def jam with a
three-year deal worth an additional
eight to ten million dollars
[Music]
if you look through his past there are a
lot of people who were at one point's
mentors to him
he picked up everything that he could he
he learned everything they had to offer
him and then when he learned all that
and he didn't need it anymore he moved
on by the end of 2004 rock aware had
grossed 300 million dollars
he bought out damon dash in rock aware
clothing for an estimated 30 million
dollars and sold it a year and a half
later to fashion giant iconics for 204
million
the guy's a genius and at any given
point if he's making a deal he's
probably the smartest guy in the room
in the back of his mind he's kind of
thinking you know
i've done business with people who are a
lot scarier than you he takes in
observations about people what they're
wearing what they're doing how they're
twitching how their face is moving
and then
when the time is right he delivers his
line he delivers his demand
he created yet another role for himself
philanthropist
instead of just making money he began to
give it away
he had previously established the sean
carter scholarship foundation for needy
students entering college in 2006 he met
with kofi annan at the un to raise
awareness for an environmental crisis
the global water shortage
every 15 seconds a child dies i'm very
excited to go out not only be a rock
star in these countries also to help it
made him a global ambassador it gave him
another dimension to who he is
as a persona you know so you just can't
typecast this guy as a rapper anymore
as ceo of def jam records jay-z
cultivated the careers of breakout
artists rihanna neo and young jeezy
but he was also ready for another hit of
his own
three years after his so-called
retirement from recording he released
kingdom come
the album sold over six hundred and
eighty thousand copies in its first week
his deal as head of def jam ended in two
thousand seven he walked away with the
future rights to his master recordings a
potential gold mine
josh taringil is a former time magazine
music editor and is now editor of
bloomberg businessweek i think what is
unique about jay-z as a business person
is that he knows exactly where he wants
to be
and he doesn't derail himself he is
opportunistic but from the very
beginning he's been very strategic as
well
he fundamentally believes that a deal
isn't successful unless the other
partner wins as well he is a win-win
kind of guy he probably tends to win a
little bit more
his long-term strategy included a series
of lucrative advertising deals with
corporate giants hp budweiser heineken
and coke he's very smart about what he's
willing to do and not willing to do he
will not bend or sacrifice his image a
good name or good will
for for money
everyone wanted to be in business with
him in april 2008 he signed a 10-year
150 million dollar deal with the concert
promotion giant live nation that
incorporated touring publishing and
recording
at a moment when record industry
revenues are really slipping
live nation approached jay-z with what's
called a 360 deal meaning they get a
piece of everything that he does and it
was brilliant for jay-z to understand
that as the pie is shrinking
throughout the music industry here's a
company offering you a much bigger pie
and guaranteeing the revenue so they
take away some of the risk and the
reward is that much greater
that same week he sealed another deal
the press discovered that he and beyonce
were married
jay-z and beyonce getting married is uh
sort of like bmw and mercedes uh
emerging makes the most powerful
celebrity brand in the world
and then the new new york anthem that
replaced sinatra the old chairman of the
board
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the blueprint three album made music
history
it was jay-z's 11th number one one more
than elvis presley the king was
dethroned by a street-savvy hip-hop
artist
i think that jay-z surpassing you know
elvis is just a remarkable feat you know
it takes him really out of the realm of
hip-hop and puts him into the upper
rungs or the highest rank of pop culture
itself he's 40 years old now he could be
a billionaire by age 50. jay-z wanted to
make his mark in the business you know
and he wanted his mark felt for a long
time his ambition
is phenomenal his ambition has a
ferocious velocity to it it's fast it's
furious he wanted to make a mark for a
long long time that's what kept this guy
going for someone to take what
essentially was kind of an outlaw
persona and become mass entertainment
and mass entertainment linked to
commerce is a tremendous achievement
he's been called the oracle of omaha the
sage of nebraska and from a young age he
knew he would be rich i could figure out
when i was 10. if i had a fairly long
life i was going to end up with a lot of
money
and behind his folksy demeanor there's
one of america's shrewdest and toughest
businessmen you don't make 40 billion
dollars by being mr rogers or by being
one of the muppets
warren takes no prisoners when it comes
to a negotiation he uses every bit of
leverage that he can
[Music]
for most of his life warren buffett has
avoided the wall street ways of risky
speculation living and working in omaha
where he was born in 1930 and where his
obsession with all things financial
began i knew i was going to be
interested in stocks the rest of my life
but probably at the time i was
you know eight or nine i used to keep
charts on all kinds of stocks when i was
uh that age my aunt gave me a
a world almanac so i'm i memorized the
population of all uh
cities of any real size but i just like
numbers it was not limited to business
numbers at all buffett's ability to
remember all those numbers would be the
bedrock of his later success
my grandfather had a grocery store and i
used to buy
coca-cola from him in six packs for a
quarter and sell them for a nickel each
i sold the saturday evening post
door-to-door i sold ladies home journal
i had all kinds of little ventures no
not all hugely successful i might add i
like doing business early on
at 16 buffett enrolled at the wharton
school of the university of pennsylvania
where he roomed with charles peterson
every day after class i spent so many
hours studying war on the contrary uh
picked up the books that are applicable
to him
and uh sat there and
flipped through him page by page
uh and he might be through two or three
courses in a couple weeks
he had a photographic uh
mind
i did not
buffett also developed an early love of
politics
i was president of the young republicans
club at the university of pennsylvania
and then i even ran for delegate to the
national convention one time as a
republican
after breezing through college buffett
got a graduate degree from columbia
business school he then headed back to
omaha to start his own business he said
i'm going to form a partnership
and he said what do you want in i said
sure i do there was only uh seven or
eight people in that original
partnership
convincing people beyond the first seven
investors got rockier my sales pitch
wasn't very effective i was i was 20
years old i looked like i was about 16
and i probably behaved like i was about
12. so i would go around and call on
people they were always nice to me
but i would see him mr smith and and
i would go through all these facts and
figures about why you should buy some
stock and when i got all through
in my head i would count to three i'll
go one two three and then
mr smith would say what does your dad
think and i would always want to hit him
but it was frustrating
buffett knew that he had to be a better
salesman so he turned to popular
self-help guru dale carnegie well i i
had to be able to communicate with
people better and i mean in groups
particularly i just knew that i couldn't
go through life terrified of public
speaking and i'd heard about the dale
carnegie course i mean i proposed to my
wife during during the dale carnegie
course so i mean i got my money's worth
right off
right during the course
buffett was finally ready to put his
career in gear he was picking stocks
that others were ignoring and his stocks
kept going up
little by little words spread around
omaha that the kid knew what he was
doing
in the first five years that buffett was
in business the dow rose by 74 percent
while buffett's investments had gone up
250 percent
in 1961 at the age of 30 he reached
millionaire status
but you couldn't tell that from the way
the family lived their home which
buffett still lives in was bought over
fifty years ago for thirty two thousand
dollars his children all went to public
schools
susie buffett is the eldest of three
buffett children we grew up in a way
that uh
i think is
probably different than most kids if
you've got a dad who has what my dad has
i mean we didn't get cars when we turned
16.
we didn't we didn't live any differently
really than most of the other kids we
knew
the biggest change in the buff of
household was that warren was moving
away from the staunch republicanism of
his father civil rights had the biggest
effect on changing my my views on
politics neither party necessarily
covered themselves with gloriana but it
was clear to me that a basic change a
really basic change in civil rights was
called for and the democrats seem to be
much more attuned to that than the
republicans in his thirties warren
buffett wanted to find companies that he
could buy a controlling interest in and
he found one a hundred miles away in
beatrice nebraska
themstrumel was a company that was
really not doing very well it was in the
windmill business of the windmills now
come back but it was not a good business
to be in 50 years ago but the stock was
selling very cheap so i started i
started buying stock in that former wall
street analyst alice schroeder is the
author of the snowball buffett's
authorized life story it was a business
that had built up a lot of inventory
that it didn't need and it had a labor
force that was too big
so it was a company that just needed to
be downsized and of course the town that
it was in was very small and it was the
main employer
a hundred people lost their jobs and
buffett took the heat
what it taught warren buffett was that
he did not want to get involved anymore
in businesses that have labor problems
where he would have to fire people where
he would have to get involved personally
in the management he wanted somebody
else to do that
buffett's next big investment also
looked like a potential failure it was a
textile mill called berkshire hathaway
whose stock was selling for seven
dollars and fifty cents a share we
bought a textile company that was
destined eventually to go out of
business just like every other new
england textile
company did it was a mistake glenn tong
is a managing partner for t2 partners
berkshire hathaway was not a good
business they didn't have a competitive
advantage that allowed them to earn a
sufficient return on the capital
invested in the business so while they
were profitable to some extent that
profitability was inexorably being
squeezed
when the cash was extracted out of
berkshire hathaway it was reinvested
first major reinvestment that was
enormously profitable was the insurance
business and that drove everything that
berkshire hathaway did from then on
andrew fry is a reporter for bloomberg
news
so he moved the company basically from
textiles to insurance
and part of the reason was because the
industry itself generated profits but
also because through the premiums that
they gathered up from their
policyholders buffett was able to take
that and make his stock investments
it's called the float
money comes in interest free from
insurance premiums which then gets
invested in other businesses
buffett also found a professional
partner who was as market savvy as he
was
charlie munger who was working as a
lawyer when the two first met
when i met warren he immediately started
telling me how much better his way of
making a living was than mine and that i
was too smart to
stay in such a silly businesses law
practice when i could go into his
business of running an investment
partnership
and it took me about two or three years
to
realize he was right
in the late 1960s wall street was in the
midst of an unprecedented boom
stock prices were soaring as everyone
rushed into the stock market but for
buffett it was time to get out i was
running a little over a hundred million
dollars and
had a lot of happy partners and i wrote
him a letter and i said
you know i don't know how to play in
this game anymore the valuations have
gotten
to where i can't find things i
terminated
my partnership in 1969.
it seems counterintuitive but warren has
always quoted gus levy who said
be greedy when others are fearful
be fearful when others are greedy and
warren knew that the party would come to
an end and at some point the bubble
would burst
buffett was 40 years old and was worth
more than 25 million dollars
but he was restless and in 1973 made a
fateful decision to buy into a
california bank called wesco
the problem was wesco was in the middle
of a merger deal with another company
and the next thing you know the company
that was going to buy westco complained
to the securities and exchange
commission that warren was trying to
bust up their merger which would have
been illegal and so an investigation
launched
the sec went through every nook and
cranny of buffett's businesses and what
they saw alarmed them
buffett and mongers investments were a
complex spiderweb of ownerships and
cross ownerships
we had drifted in since we had several
companies so the whole thing looked like
so much spaghetti that had been done for
some
evil master purpose
we didn't feel we'd done anything
improper but there were a lot of rules
and and the question was whether we
violated any
stanley sporkin was director of
enforcement at the sec anytime you find
that things are so wired
that they take a long time to be able to
understand them raises a suspicion that
maybe somebody is doing that to get away
with something
what also raised investigators
suspicions was that monger and buffett
were offering westco shareholders a
higher price for their stock than they
could get on the open market
so we just kept buying until our
allotment ran out at two or three points
higher than
we had to well that was a very eccentric
thing to do but we thought it was the
right way to behave and the sec went
berserk
trying to head off disaster buffett's
lawyer made an unorthodox appeal to
stanley sporkin and saying look as stan
even though
this doesn't look good from your
standpoint i want you to take into
account the character of the individual
my view meaning rickerson's review he
probably is going to be the number one
person in the financial services
industry
of all time
the appeal worked buffett's company was
fined just over a hundred thousand
dollars but no charges were filed
against buffett
in 1973 berkshire hathaway stock price
hit a new high of 93 dollars its profits
driven mostly by their insurance
businesses
buffett also owned stakes in banks
clothing makers and candy factories
but there was one business he was
passionate about owning i love
newspapers i mean i started reading
newspapers you know my dad would bring
him home one day i don't know whether it
was six or seven or eight and it was the
first thing i'd grab my sisters would
grab them too we all like to read it
his first newspaper purchase was an
omaha weekly called the sun
the paper won a pulitzer prize a rare
honor for a small publication
he then started acquiring stock in the
washington post company the paper was
struggling financially after the
watergate scandal
1973
the stock had gone down a lot partly in
response to the fact that
the nixon administration has sort of
declared war on the washington post
[Applause]
the interesting thing is is when we were
buying that stock at twenty dollars a
share if you'd asked the people who were
selling it to us how much the company
was actually worth the businesses they
would have said a hundred dollars a
share but they sold it anyway i salute
the nixon administration forever for
stirring up the dust at that time
buffett's rule had always been to keep
his distance from his company's managers
and executives
but that was not the case at the
washington post where publisher
katherine graham became his social
partner and
confidante she was in a business that
fascinated me so she would invite me to
these various washington parties which
were interesting i mean i i saw
parts of the world that i wouldn't have
seen otherwise
if we hadn't become friends
but as buffett's social circle widened
his wife susie was feeling increasingly
isolated back home and made a bold
decision she was not divorcing warren
but she left omaha for san francisco to
pursue a new life i get why she moved my
dad was getting more famous and my
mother was so not the mrs warren buffett
type
their relationship never changed at all
they were completely in love with each
other
they talked five six seven eight times a
day they traveled together
she just couldn't live here
to make sure that warren was taken care
of in her absence susie turned to her
friend astrid menks within a few months
ostrid moved in
it's very unorthodox a lot of people i'm
sure
talked about it and had all kinds of
lovely things to say about how weird it
was but i also think you know what it's
nobody's business what goes on in
somebody else's relationship it worked
for the three of them it worked buffett
made history when he helped finance
capital city's takeover of the american
broadcasting company the biggest media
deal to date
but his golden touch wouldn't be enough
when buffett invested 700 million
dollars in solomon brothers at the time
the nation's largest investment house
a few years after buffett's initial
investment solomon got into big trouble
it turned sour when i got a call in
august of i guess 1991 they sort of
hinted to me about the problems that
were coming a traitor named mosher had
done some very bad things in the
government us government bond market
those bad things included illegal moves
by that solomon trader to corner the
bond market by using unauthorized
accounts to increase solomon's share and
force out their competitors
derek mourn was a vice chairman at
solomon brothers though he had no
involvement in the scandal he was
appalled at what was happening
to me it was clear that we've broken the
law we've interfered with the workings
of a critical market
and that the treasury in the fed would
be
less than amused
as ceo of solomon brothers john good
friend was taking the blame for the mess
i remember it vividly
when you make the front page in the
right-hand column of new york times in
your picture
but you're a fool which i probably was
my distribute became national
should have been one of the worst days
of my life
and probably was
i told
tom strauss
and john merriweather that we had to go
talk on wall street that solomon's top
officials were offering to resign to
prevent the firm's possible debarment as
a primary dealer in treasury securities
good friend made one last desperate
attempt to salvage the company with a
phone call to omaha nebraska asking
buffett to be the ceo
and i wasn't involved in the things so
that i was not tainted the hope was that
i would be credible
with all the people that were mad at us
there were a lot of them
the crisis deepened when treasury
secretary nicholas brady ruled that
solomon was out of the bond business
it was announced that about 10 in the
morning on a sunday the u.s treasury had
knocked us off the list of a really
acceptable people primary dealers that
would have been a death blow to the
company so i had to get that changed
by
the time tokyo opened that would have
been a national calamity and it looked
for a long time
as though the government was just going
to say the hell with you solomon warren
buffett spent the entire day in frantic
phone calls to washington trying to get
the feds to back off
i was scared stiff and it probably came
through in my voice
there were a lot of people that wanted
us to go out of business over that
weekend and i didn't know what was going
to happen
at the 11th hour secretary brady gave
solomon another chance
to seal the deal buffett had to
personally take charge of cleaning up
the mess at solomon it was miserable i
was there nine months and four days and
it's not an accident that i can tell you
20 years later exactly how long it was
there but
but it was important that it get done i
wouldn't wish it on anybody and i
wouldn't wish what happened to the firm
you know on anybody but in a sense i
learned a lot buffett emerged the hero
warren buffett meeting with the
financial community signing autographs
they love him the man with the squeaky
clean image who's trying to clean up the
mess at solomon brothers
in 1993 berkshire hathaway stock hit 17
000 a share and buffett was world famous
but no amount of global traveling could
change some of buffett's ingrained
habits let's talk about warren's diet
here are the vegetables he'll eat
corn on the cob
french fries hash browns and the fruit
would be
a banana cream pie strawberry shortcake
i think that's the end of the fruit he
also drinks you know several cherry
cokes a day i've never in my life and
i'm not kidding seen the man drink a sip
of water
ever
the 1990s and 2000s would be the era of
berkshire hathaway's greatest expansion
brought into the corporate fold was the
nation's biggest furniture store
a leading mobile home manufacturer
fruit of the loom underwear benjamin
moore paints dairy queen geico insurance
over 70 companies in all with a combined
250 000 employees
some investments flew in the face of
conventional wisdom he bought his
hometown newspaper the omaha world
herald
and he bought the burlington northern
railroad
that is the thing that warren buffett
has done over and over as he invests in
something and then everybody looks at it
and says
i saw it there why didn't i recognize
these things all along
in omaha berkshire hathaway's annual
meeting has become a place of pilgrimage
for tens of thousands of shareholders
it's really an amazing thing the stadium
is filled and the spotlights are on a
small folding table with two 80 year
olds at that table and those two 80 year
olds have more stamina than anyone else
in the room
goes non-stop from friday to sunday
night
and and as the weekend goes on he gets
more energy
can't explain it it's got to be those
burgers
in the 2000s buffett was worth tens of
billions of dollars
money he planned on giving away to a
foundation to be run by his wife susie
but in 2004 susie died of a stroke
following cancer surgery
it was a huge shock for all of us my dad
i can't i can't explain
how much he loved her and how much he
relied on her i am going to start crying
talking about this um
it
you know he'll never totally get over it
none of us probably will but she was
really something very special
two years after his wife susie's death
buffett married ostrich menks in a
private ceremony
and he announced that he was pledging
the bulk of his fortune not to his
children but to the foundation run by
bill and melinda gates
bill gates has been one of buffett's
closest friends since the early 1990s
so it was you know kind of phenomenal
it made us step up our ambition level
at a lot of things we wouldn't have been
able to do and
so now every year it's a gigantic gift
that allows us to be double what we
would have been without it
buffett's reputation was as much
celebrity as brilliant businessman
when the u.s economy plunged into crisis
mode in 2008 warren buffett was again
seen as a savior to many of the
financial institutions collapsing under
mountains of debt
the dow closed monday session down more
than 500 points warren buffett is one
enormous good housekeeping seal of
approval and if he's putting money into
a situation they're going to assume that
he's intelligent enough to be making
that investment because he thinks he's
going to generate a satisfactory return
off of it and that will calm people's
fears when fear is at its highest among
the businesses that received lifelines
from warren buffett were goldman sachs
ge and later bank of america
but as buffett continues into his
eighties one question persists
who will succeed this financial icon at
the head of berkshire hathaway a
successor has been identified but that
name has not yet been made public
what he has made public are the
political and economic causes that he
feels passionate about i think in the
last couple years
he has seen
some
places where he thinks if i open my
mouth it might make a difference
what he's most vocal about is what he
sees as the inequities of the tax system
something that's come to be known as the
buffett rule there's all kinds of
ultra-rich who pay normal taxes but
there are there's a small segment but
you can find them very easily who pay
very low taxes including me
he considers himself you know
lucky to have been born in america at
this time in history
well i think he's one of the most
memorable people i've ever met
he's touched a lot of lives
with what he's done
and everybody that he's dealt with has
made money doing it and it's improved
their life
there are really no people like warren
where
you know we should sit back and
and benefit from the deep thinking he's
done about
business
since he was very young
i just have a great time every day i
mean i i am beginning to do exactly what
i want to do in life but it doesn't get
any better than that
he is ruthless he is tenacious he is
ingenious
he's a media tycoon who created a global
empire worth more than 80 billion
dollars he has an extraordinary passion
for the media business he is in it 24
hours a day seven days a week he eats
sleeps and drinks it success does not
come quickly or easily in the media
news corps rubert murdoch is a
modern-day press baron who rules
newspapers and magazines television
networks and cable channels film studios
and satellite systems
often reflecting the message of their
provocative and polarizing chairman his
editors know what rupert wants and
they're quite happy to carry that out
for more than 50 years murdoch has been
building his kingdom one piece at a time
along the way attracting a firestorm of
controversy rupert murdoch is the
embodiment of evil it's no longer the
respected paper that it once was and
sparking bitter rivalries
it's a newspaper war there's always
someone who must die in order for you to
live
and rupert is good at that battle
because he can take more pain than
anybody else
those battles have taken his company
from the heights of success to the brink
of collapse and back rupert is mainly
interested in power
you could almost say a megalomania
to own as much as he can to
influence as much as he can to be the
biggest and best that ever was or ever
will be rupert murdoch has been called
many things even on his own network i'm
rivet murdoch the billionaire tarrant
and this is my sky box if you're rupert
murdoch prove it
[Music]
murdoch's presence in film television
and print is felt in nearly every part
of the globe rupert murdoch is what god
meant when he created a media executive
he has all the attributes that a media
executive is supposed to have he has
vision he has guts he'll take a risk
he'll go to the edge
his empire started with a small
newspaper in australia and became one of
the biggest media companies in the world
with over 150 newspapers international
television operations and a movie studio
news corp pulls in yearly revenues of
some 32 billion dollars
the man who controls so much of what we
see in the media declined to be
interviewed about his own life here
he has never been one to hide his
political agenda i would say supported
the bush policy right in the middle east
we've been very critical of its
execution or disguise his ambition
extremely ruthless
knew what he wanted and nothing would
stop him from getting what he wanted
and i think that's probably been his
hallmark the whole of his life
the beginning and the core of his empire
the newspaper
michael wolff is the author of the man
who owns the news this is a man who grew
up in the newspaper business found
success in the newspaper business
literally loves the newspaper business
i've seen him read a newspaper and it's
a physical act it's as physical as
literally making love to a woman
that obsession was in his genes
rupert murdoch was born on march 11 1931
to prominent newspaper man sir keith
murdoch and his wife lady elizabeth
murdoch
he grew up on the family farm outside
melbourne australia
he was sent to the exclusive g-long
boarding school near melbourne i don't
know whether i enjoyed it or not i
didn't think so at the time but looking
back on it most of my memories are
certainly happy ones
but he felt out of place surrounded by
the children of melbourne's elite andrew
butcher is the former senior vice
president of corporate affairs and
communications for news corp
rupert was definitely from a privileged
background
but
his father didn't own the business that
he worked in he managed it rupert always
saw himself as an outsider he thrived on
that it gave him a competitive edge
he would set himself apart further when
he went on to oxford where his
attraction to communist philosophy
earned him a nickname red rupert
that was probably the product of a young
man's rebellious spirit i'm sure he
would have rebelled against his parents
where he could and against his parents
values just like most young people
mungo mccallum was a young journalist in
australia who would later work with
murdoch i think a lot of what drove
rupert murdoch particularly in those
days was the desire to live up to his
father's reputation it was a fraught
relationship i think his father was
quite remote hard to get a kind word out
of a way a lot but in hindsight rupert
has enormous amount of affection for his
father
all for what he attained and
determination to
make his father proud
in october of 1952 while at oxford
murdoch received the devastating news
that his father had died at age 67 after
having battled heart problems and cancer
returning home he found his mother under
pressure from his father's colleagues to
sell off their newspaper holdings rupert
was appalled at the way that his mother
was treated and the lack of respect for
his father after his death
part of the estate at risk of being sold
was the adelaide news a struggling
tabloid with a circulation of only 75
000. a few months after finishing at
oxford murdoch moved home to australia
to take control
his fingerprints were soon on every part
of the operation he was extremely
hands-on i know from my experience of
his editing skills that they were they
were certainly the equal of anyone's
in 1958 he made his first foray into a
different medium television with channel
9 a small local outlet
peter chernin is the former president
and chief operating officer of news corp
i think one of the things that people
don't remember is you know rupert owned
a television network back in australia
um
as early as i think the late 50s early
60s so and it's sort of one of the
things that brought him here you know he
had been buying
re-run rights and rights to movies from
american studios and from
american networks
the station's value took off
murdoch was soon buying up a variety of
local newspapers including the daily
mirror a popular lowbrow sydney tabloid
but murdoch's goal was to start a
national newspaper
in 1964 he launched the australian
he was told from the beginning that it
couldn't possibly work that the
distances were too vast
that there was not enough national
advertising to sustain it he was told
that he wouldn't be able to get the
staff for it because no good journalist
would want to work on a paper which was
so clearly doomed to failure
the paper had a liberal stance right
from the start and the man in charge was
ever present
if it was running through the office up
and down virtually every night and it
wasn't uncommon for rupert to stride
into the paper quite late at night about
10 o'clock around deadline time
usually wearing a bright yellow raincoat
and occasionally confused with a cleaner
by one of the staff who didn't know him
very well
murdoch's hands-on command of his papers
established itself early i get very
involved in
in the newspapers themselves on the
other hand i think that i give my
editors
tremendous freedom at age 25 murdoch
married and had a daughter prudence
the marriage ended in divorce after 11
years
in 1967 he married his second wife anna
torv
over the next five years they had three
children elizabeth lachlan and james
what's important to murdoch is his
family and his company i actually think
those things are absolutely connected in
his
in his mind as he matured murdoch grew
more conservative in his views rupert
became more and more captive of the
business community in sydney
and when rupert went to the cruising
yacht club the other members were always
taunting him about oh how's that red rag
of a paper of yours going now rupert
and this i think eventually got to him
rupert i think is mainly interested in
power you could almost say megalomania
to own as much as he can to
influence as much as he can to be the
biggest and best that ever was or ever
will be
by the late 1960s rupert murdoch had
landed on another continent and into one
of the world's most competitive markets
and the very definition of old
establishment london's fleet street
he ran headlong into the notorious media
tycoon robert maxwell
it became murdoch's david against
maxwell's goliath
murdoch established a pattern of going
to battle against his well-known
competitors you can look at rupert's
business strategy as newspaper strategy
it's a newspaper war there's always
someone who must die in order for you to
live
with a one-two punch he out-maneuvered
maxwell and purchased the popular and
gossipy news of the world and later the
faltering daily the sun he remade it
revived it
built it in a very short time into a
powerhouse readership was largely men
involved a kind of combination of sports
sex
scandal a little bit of politics
and the page three girls
topless girls and um
and it worked charlie beckett is a media
analyst at the london school of
economics i think the sun newspaper
love it or loathe it and millions of
people love it and buy it has had an
extraordinary cultural impact both for
good if you like and for evil and it's
delivered in a style that's engaged the
public in some very real issues and it's
been of course a fantastic commercial
success now murdoch set his sights on a
new world to conquer america he was
never comfortable in australia and never
comfortable in the in the uk but he
arrived here and almost immediately he
thought this is home
that home became new york
in 1973 rupert murdoch and his family
settled on new york's affluent upper
east side
he was hungry to expand
but to break into the u.s market he had
to settle for a small regional paper he
buys a paper in san antonio texas he
bought it because he could afford to buy
it
next murdoch wanted a national presence
so he started a paper that would become
the star hoping to compete with the
lurid national enquirer
the star struggled to shine
tabloids are sold in supermarkets in
america which means that they have to be
for women not men
and it was never a wholly successful
experiment for him
nevertheless he later sold a recharged
star to the parent company of the
national enquirer for 400 million
dollars
but it was a fading liberal tabloid the
new york post that captured his
imagination
in 1976 he handed over 30 million
dollars for the paper
a few weeks later in the face of
employee opposition he added the new
york magazine company for 7.5 million
dollars
the purchase included the liberal
village voice it would be hard to think
of a publication
less likely to belong to rupert murdoch
than the village voice
the voice returned a handsome profit
eight years later murdoch sold it for 55
million dollars
murdoch was now on the map in new york
he was featured on the cover of time
magazine in january of 1977 as king kong
towering over the city grasping its most
influential publications including his
pet project the post
martin singerman is the former publisher
of the new york post the paper had been
allowed to really dwindle and die if you
will rupert murdoch invested more in the
publication both in terms of
money substantially in in people we
invested in presses a year and a half
later
to bring color to the newspaper added
pages
and did the things that you you would do
in order to make a more
substantial publication
murdoch's instincts revived the paper
with attention-grabbing headlines
inside news of the day combined with
juicy gossip sports coverage horoscopes
and games no headlines sell papers but
for the long run when you have a daily
newspaper
there has to be substance because people
aren't going to buy
once look at it and find nothing so it
really is a two-step process
the post became a new york favorite
financially it was a disaster losing
millions of dollars every year
ron grover is a business journalist
i don't really think rupert's in it to
win uh in terms of of the bottom line he
likes the idea that it gives him a place
at the table he likes the idea that he
can get his position out there he likes
the idea that he gets entre to
politicians
by 1980 rupert murdoch was a major
player in the new york media scene
he continued to claim he gave his
editors tremendous freedom but that
message didn't always make it to the
staff wrote headlines
shaped stories
dictated the leagues of stories rupert
was everywhere somebody said to him mr
murdock this seems to be
a contradiction you said that
you allow your editors
to run the newspaper
and
he said there's no contradiction i just
know the editors i hire there is rupert
and then there are the people under him
he likes to hire people who are grateful
to him for having been hired he likes to
hire people whose loyalty he can count
on he does not like to hire people who
might compete with him
might feel that they are on the same
footing as him the way that he
has influence and control through his
news organizations is not really by
screaming down the phone there is more
of a sense that his editors they know
what rupert wants and they're quite
happy to carry that out
what rupert wanted soon began to play
out in a decade-long spending spree in
1981 he bought the prestigious times and
the sunday times of london
back in the states he scooped up the
boston herald and the chicago sun times
and once again he was met with a revolt
four top executives of the sun time said
they were resigning including publisher
james hull syndicated columnist mike
royko has taken a leave of absence i i i
would never work for a newspaper with
the county descent in new york the
county presented boston guys out of san
antonio
they're trash
and none of that phased murdock he
wouldn't stop at newspapers in 1985 he
does the deal to buy 20th century fox a
deal of quintessential importance
because what it is is a crossover here's
a man who's in the publishing business
and now he's buying a movie studio
he paid former oil man marvin davis 250
million dollars for a 50 percent stake
in the studio he had a hard time getting
the first 50 from marvin davis
but he was able to pick the other 50 up
for the relative bargain of 325 million
dollars so he took full ownership of the
20th century fox film studio
a multi-billion dollar asset now
for about half a billion dollars
he once told me that the movies are the
the sizzle you need the sizzle when you
have the rest of the of the media empire
and and so he knows he needs it because
of what it's what brings creative people
to the enterprise
that sizzle could also singe especially
in the notoriously risky multi-million
dollar movie business
one of the great things about rupert
which is in a crisis he is the coolest
calmest and
if he supports you and he believes in
you he'll back you
all the way to the wall you know he's
not a guy who sort of starts worrying
about it or starts going wringing his
hands
if he believes in you
and you're being straight with him and
you convince him of the appropriateness
of your decision he's
the best guy you could ever want in the
foxhole with you
murdoch was anxious to expand his
enterprise by buying into the united
states television market but he faced a
serious obstacle there's an fcc rule
that says you must be a united states
citizen to own a tv station and rupert
who's ever the pragmatist decided well
if that's what it takes i'm going to
become a us citizen on september 4th
1985 rupert murdoch took the oath to
become a naturalized american
sir rod eddington is the former ceo of
british airways and a close friend when
rupert gave up his australian
citizenship to take american citizenship
there was some criticism of him for
doing that but the business is based in
america its major market is in america
and he's chosen to live in america
so it's not as if he embraced american
citizenship only for the purposes of
being a media baron in america he's
chosen to make his life in america
and his ultimate mark
murdoch had a master plan
he paid metro media's john kluge up to
two billion dollars to buy television
stations in six major markets
they formed the nucleus of what would
become fox television network
there was abc nbc cbs and there was no
room on the dial for another network
well suddenly rupert comes along and
he's able to launch a fourth network he
could see that there was great scope for
a network that attracted younger viewers
and a more diverse range of viewers but
the new network badly misfired with
their high profile debut
this is the bleep button we are going to
be live and that means no bleep
the late show starring joan rivers
failed miserably against the unshakable
johnny carson for the young team at fox
it was a big lesson
garth ansir is the former president of
fox television no one had started a
network since the 1950s understanding
what would make a network differentiated
from nbc abc cbs which were really the
real competitors then
was
something that we had to discover by
trial and error i mean it seems obvious
in retrospect that oh yeah if you run
when cbs is running you won't succeed
fox set about attracting top talent like
series creators james brooks and stephen
cannell
it was a combination of some creative
freedom certainly more than the other
networks were going to give them but we
gave larger orders we would go directly
to series and some of that was just
because we had to we had only a year to
get the network up and running
from from scratch
beating the odds with a host of shows
that countered the competition the
fourth network began to register in the
ratings
[Music]
twin lane jump street young cop show
married children you know irreverent
family show i mean the working title of
married children was not the cosby's and
living color and all those things became
much more i get it that has to be
different from what you can get on the
other channels and nothing was more
different than the show that would
change everything the single biggest
turning point was the simpsons ow
ow
would it hey what's with this ow
rupert always loved setting the network
schedule more than anything he was like
a kid in a candy store and i used to
joke because he'd jump up and start
putting squares up on the board and sort
of say how's that and we go well it's
really not not that good okay okay and
then you move it and put something else
up but rupert jumped up at one point and
and took simpsons
and put it on thursday night against the
cosby show you know he's talking about
putting this tiny little show that we're
just getting started up against the
number one show on television
and at first honestly we all thought he
was crazy we said we can't do that we'll
get killed we'll get annihilated and he
kept saying you know trust me i think
it'll work that move of the simpsons
against cosby was a hundred percent
rupert's idea while rupert murdoch was
expanding into american television an
ocean away in london he triggered a
revolt from the powerful british press
unions
this should be the print capital of the
world and all that work has gone out
because of the activities of the london
print unions
in an effort to automate his newspaper
production murdoch moved it from fleet
street to a plant in the dockside area
of london called whopping
the efficient new plant needed fewer
workers to make it run 5 500 fewer
workers
murdoch planned to lay them all off as
the former general secretary of the
british printing union sogat baroness
brenda dean negotiated with murdoch to
try and save jobs
he'd taken the view understandably he
wasn't going to move out of fleet street
with the old work practices into a new
plant that didn't need the ill work
practices what he wanted was an
extremely radical deal on
the employment practices in the company
and he wasn't going to get it we were
still prepared to negotiate and he
listened and he said at the end of it
the music has changed
but the dance remains the same
unknown to brenda dean murdoch had
already made a secret deal with the
electricians union to run the plant and
quickly move forward with a trial print
run
and then of course once we knew that and
once we knew they were running trial
runs
then for the first time as general
secretary i said to our people
stop
take strike action
[Music]
what they're tonight
murdoch received support from an old
friend margaret thatcher who favored
management over unions
he had backed the conservative thatcher
when she was a candidate for prime
minister and it was paying off
mrs thatcher's government passed
legislation and in the news
international dispute the whopping
dispute as it became known
that
what was known as the anti-union
legislation became a key factor in
ensuring that rupert murdoch achieved
what he wanted to
thousands came out to support the
protests but the demonstrations would
take a violent turn
whopping was called fortress whopping
because it really was there was security
essentially a a murdoch militia was
called out
and and he was demonized
we did have some pretty awful stuff
there i mean i saw some of my members
beaten up by police violence did arrive
on the scene there's no doubt about that
and it was something that we tried to
control and sometimes we couldn't with
the help of thatcher murdoch crushed the
unions and his plant at whopping was
soon roaring ahead
he took a big gamble on this occasion
and it took a long time getting there
and it was extremely destructive for the
company and his reputation in the uk
but he got what he wanted in the end he
was the boogeyman the guy who broke
labor's back
this turns out to be a seminal moment in
not only the history of labor but in the
history of modernity itself you know he
said this is not reasonable this is not
logical progress dictates that we change
the rules
undaunted murdoch's shopping spree
continued
in 1988 he shelled out three billion
dollars to acquire the annenberg
magazine empire that included 17 the
racing form and tv guide
murdoch's shocking price was the highest
ever paid for a publishing company but
that same year he was tripped up by
federal regulations prohibiting
ownership of a newspaper and a
television station in a single market
as a result murdoch was temporarily
forced to sell his beloved new york post
he was able to buy it back years later
for 25 million dollars after obtaining a
special waiver he's kept the post alive
because he wants it alive no one else in
in news corporation wants the new york
post alive save for rupert and the
people who work at the post
it just makes no no economic sense
undiminished murdoch reached for the sky
literally his next big gamble was on
satellite television
david hill is the senior executive vice
president of 21st century fox for him to
start sky television
up against a hugely funded
establishment uh satellite platform
called british satellite broadcasting
was one of the greatest gamblers of all
time nearly nearly bankrupted the
company
that heralded this explosion
of television throughout europe and the
rest of the world in 1990 sky merged
with british satellite broadcasting to
form b sky b
murdoch maintained 39 of the company but
the return on his investment was in a
downward spiral
b sky b was hemorrhaging money and his
spending spree had put murdoch
dangerously in debt with creditors
fortunately 145 banks decided to give
him more time
however one bank in pittsburgh refused
and threatened to call in a 10 million
loan the way he had sort of set up this
covenant of of of banks is that if one
demanded the loan that they all all of
the loans came due it was a desperate
11th hour call from murdoch to the bank
in pittsburgh that brought his company
back from the brink of collapse
that was this incredible accomplishment
in which he managed to save the company
he had to sell off parts of it to sell
the magazines and had to commit himself
to
better business practices the banks have
told him he has to behave himself
he had to restructure nearly eight
billion dollars in debt it was a
near-death experience for his company
and a defining moment for murdoch
he was deal a minute rupert before this
and now he's it's much more structured
still in 1993 he was back at the poker
table he forked over one billion dollars
for the chinese television network star
tv
porter bib is an american media analyst
and publisher
rupert murdoch first
entered china through star the
the the satellite television network
that he uh built in hong kong and he had
uh in the early 90s
broad and wide access to what was
essentially a closed media market for
the rest of western broadcasters but on
september 1st 1993 he squandered it
murdoch made a speech in london that
inflamed the chinese government advances
in the technology of telecommunications
have proved an unambiguous threat to
totalitarian regimes everywhere
the chinese retaliated by banning
private ownership of satellite dishes
and with them murdoch's access to
millions of chinese homes
star tv was under siege
murdoch had to placate the chinese
government so he removed from star a
frequent source of their anger the bbc
he also killed an unflattering book
about china written by the former
governor of hong kong
chinese leadership soon after expressed
admiration for the gestures
and murdoch would continue from then on
to court chinese officials to expand
news corp's often tense presence in
china china is the new world it's it is
the future and he sees this earlier and
more dramatically than most people but
almost nothing works out in china his
competitor becomes the chinese
government and he can't compete with the
chinese government
rupert murdoch is not much of a sports
fan even so in december of 1993 he took
aim at an american obsession football
and he scored
with a breathtaking bid of over one and
a half billion dollars he snatched the
rights to nfc games from cbs and stunned
the wide world of sports
i don't think we've ever done a deal
where we haven't woken up the next
morning with buyer's remorse
and and i i think in a way that's good
because it spurs you to work even harder
for the nfl it could have been a major
fumble
i think the nfl was very brave it was a
gutsy kill on their part because
fox had nothing it was it didn't have a
sports division so in reality and john
madden's great joke was we shouldn't be
glad i saw fox sports where fox sport
singular
they took a huge risk
it was it was like what were they going
to do
if we screwed it up
what would have happened if our pregame
show was a shambles
that the set fell apart and then when we
start covering it we're missing
touchdowns we haven't got this the
announcers are wrong
[Music]
and what if he couldn't reach all the
americans who loved football
murdoch didn't blink
to get more eyeballs he invested another
500 million dollars in new world
communications owned by the savvy
investor ronald perlman
perlman then switched the affiliation of
12 of his prime major market television
stations to fox
it was the biggest realignment of
affiliates in us broadcast history and a
bonanza for the local stations
the nfl on fox generates over 900
million dollars a year and has a weekly
audience of up to 20 million viewers
murdoch was on a roll
but the high roller wanted to get back
to his roots he's found himself in the
television business which he doesn't
like i i don't think the man has ever
watched in a full hour of prime time tv
but he likes of course the news business
by the mid 1990s rupert murdoch had his
sights set on buying the only 24-hour
cable news network cnn but its owner ted
turner was contemptuous of murdoch's
politics and pretensions and the feeling
was mutual
[Applause]
turner eventually and reluctantly sold
cnn but not to murdoch
in 1996 the cable news channel went to
time warner as part of a 7.5 billion
dollar merger with turner broadcasting
murdock had to come up with another
approach
he never flinched and created his own
channel to go head-to-head with cnn
welcome to washington i'm brett hume fox
news quickly established itself as a
bully pulpit for conservative views part
of the business plan is you shouldn't
compete with cnn you should go for an
audience that is underserved and you
should do it in a in a way that's
cheaper than having to send reporters
around the world so we just have
opinions and that's what works and works
um incredibly well
to run it he hired roger ailes a former
consultant to conservative politicians
and republican presidents from richard
nixon to george bush
rupert by his nature is a little
conservative not as conservative perhaps
as roger hills is but what he liked was
the fact that roger had a plan for fox
news fox news in its early days lost a
lot of money rupert actually had to pay
cable companies to take it
it was lively controversial and drove
liberals crazy don't take your cheap
little pathetic shot i am telling you
that you're taking cheap little pathetic
shots americans and indeed our foreign
allies who actively work against our
military once the war is underway will
be considered enemies of the state by me
with a slogan of fair and balanced
former president and ceo of news corp
peter chernin insists that fox news
makes a distinction between the news of
the day and its talk shows there's news
on fox news
which i happen to believe is actually uh
you know very neutral and moderate and
presented fairly and then there's talk
and opinion shows which no one ever
pretends are news or factual and you
know bill o'reilly or sean hannity are
clearly
people on the right side of the spectrum
but they've always been presented as
such
the fox news channel has soared past cnn
to become the dominant and most
profitable cable news network in the
united states but turmoil was brewing in
murdoch's personal life
he divorced his wife anna after thirty
two years in nineteen ninety nine it was
one of the largest divorce settlements
in history
and sixty eight-year-old murdoch
immediately married thirty-year-old
wendy dung a graduate of the yale school
of management and former vice president
of star tv
murdoch's personal life appeared
recharged but less than a year later he
was diagnosed with prostate cancer
but he perseveres through this and in
fact goes on to have one child and then
another child so at the age of
70
he has his daughter grace and then at 72
has his daughter
chloe
in 2003 at age 72 rupert murdoch went
after yet another glorious television
prize directv
he had wanted a satellite
business in the united states for a
decade he dealt with the board of
general motors for close to two years to
get a deal done they eventually sold to
rupert grudgingly and he finally won
directv
his 6.6 billion offer gave him a 34
stake
but in a bizarre series of events only
one year later murdoch had to give it up
while celebrating the returns of george
bush's election in thousand four murdoch
overlooked that a huge block of his
company's news corp stock shares came on
the market in australia
american media mogul john malone not
surprisingly was paying attention and
snatched them up when they were
transferred to the us market rupert woke
up one morning and said holy cow this
guy owns 16 percent of my company
he could be dangerous because he
understands that john malone is a really
smart businessman
malone's stake in news corp was now the
second largest after murdock's
to get that chunk of his company back
rupert had to part with something of
substantial value
to get rid of john malone in the end he
basically had to swap that stake for
direct television i think he might have
wanted to hang on to direct television
he's become a really really strong
operator in television and rupert
doesn't have a national distribution out
he probably would have liked that
after reclaiming his stock murdoch moved
on with a 2005 purchase of the social
networking site myspace
once again he moved swiftly and paid a
huge price to beat out a rival this time
viacom's sumner redstone
rupert's experience with the internet is
a
um a comic one perhaps from his point of
view a tragic comic one myspace which
was you know he bought for i don't know
i think
somewhat more than 500 million dollars
at one point they thought it was worth
25 billion dollars and it's you know
it's worth scrap now
the effort was considered a disaster
facebook left myspace in the dust
before long murdoch returned to his
natural element refocusing his eyes on
one of the most prestigious and
treasured newspapers in the world
sarah ellison is the author of war at
the wall street journal and was a former
reporter for the paper when i talked to
people about
murdoch and his lust for the wall street
journal even his children said they
couldn't remember a time when he wasn't
talking about the newspaper the wall
street journal and its parent company
dow jones were owned by the bancrofts a
prominent boston family who were largely
hands-off owners i mean he's tried to
buy the wall street journal three times
before and they
they just dismiss him um
you know in an incredibly
haughty snobbish way
when he first learned about
the divisions within the bancroft family
that had owned the newspaper for over
100 years that was sort of blood in the
water
murdoch seized the moment and made an
offer
the stock was trading for thirty six
dollars a share
murdoch offered a stunning sixty dollars
a share
jim ottaway is former vice president and
director of dow jones i certainly
remember my reaction which was shock
feeling of great disappointment that my
life and journalism would end
with the company i worked hard for to
make really great
newspapers at the wall street journal to
have them taken over by a man who i did
not admire as a newspaper publisher
the staggering offer split the bancroft
family even further
at one point there were
children threatening to sue their
parents
if they agreed to sell to murdoch i
thought he would damage the quality of
the wall street journal if he applied
the journalistic principles that he's
had followed
most of his life which included
attacking his enemies
supporting his friends supporting
politicians who could help him get
business advantages
murdoch promised he would maintain the
quality of the paper and keep the staff
are you going to give four independence
to the wall street journal i'm not
saying anymore
i had seen that time and again he had
made promises to owners and then broken
them
very soon he said he would maintain the
standards of the times of london and
guarantee he wouldn't change the editor
harry evans and within about a year he'd
fired evans
faced with few options and no offer that
was as attractive as murdoch's six
billion dollars the bancrofts gave in
on august first 2007 dow jones entered
into an agreement with news corp that
handed murdoch the wall street journal
i'm privy to to to his incredible
excitement over acquiring the journal
this enormous feeling of satisfaction
and this rethinking of of his of his own
life he's going to really spend time at
the journal not everyone was as excited
about that
we're here today to tell everyone to
make sure that they know that rupert
murdoch has bought the wall street
journal
predictably murdoch soon broke the
promises he'd made and brought in his
own people and it was kind of through
the back door that he managed to deflate
the culture and puncture the egos of the
people who were at the wall street
journal in one in one sort of fell swoop
but murdoch surprised many of his
critics eventually the wall street
journal surpassed usa today to become
the number one daily paper in america
[Music]
rupert murdoch a lion in winter turned
80 in 2011.
after 60 years as the leader of a media
empire there were questions as to who
would follow him
i think he looks forward to the day when
all three of his children that are
interested in the business work for him
together i think he looks forward to the
day when it's rupert times four
murdoch bought his daughter elizabeth's
tv production company shine for nearly
700 million dollars in 2011
lachlan after an ill-fated career at
news corp returned to australia to run
the 10 television network
murdoch's youngest son james was named
newscorp's new deputy chief operating
officer in new york
i'm very competitive and we're very
competitive uh to the extent that where
we need to take market share we're going
to go ahead and take it that murdoch
competitive spirit seeped into the
company culture with devastating
consequences
media reports disclosed allegations that
the murdoch-owned tabloid news of the
world tapped the voicemails of a teenage
murder victim and her family and paid
police for information
i think initially this was seen as
another sordid little journalism scandal
of some journalists who had gone too far
with private investigators and what we
thought was a relatively limited scandal
turns out to have been a pervasive
systematic abuse
of journalistic power
the mobile phones of celebrities and
politicians were also hacked
so it turns out this phone hacking was a
widespread and even ubiquitous that it
was being done
to virtually everybody
who had the possibility of offering any
news or gossip to contain the scandal
the 168 year old news of the world was
shut down in july 2011.
murdoch apologized to a british
parliamentary committee
just like to say one sentence this is
the most humble day of my life
he blamed his staff for misleading him
about the hacking people i trusted
i'm not saying who i don't know what
level
they let me down and i think they
behaved uh disgracefully and betrayed
the company and me
in the middle of the hearing a protester
tried to attack murdoch with a pie
his wife wendy physically defended
the scandal has been damaging and costly
james the heir apparent stepped down as
chairman of b sky b
and news corp has spent over 380 million
dollars in legal fees and settlements
two years after wendy murdoch defended
her husband rupert murdoch filed for
divorce
knocked down but not out murdoch
launched fox sports network to compete
with espn
and to placate shareholders in june 2013
murdoch split his six decade old
publishing business from the rest of his
media empire while the sky's the limit
the new company officially starts
trading today it's already the largest
newspaper publisher in the united states
with a market value of 8.8 billion
dollars
[Music]
rupert murdoch has built a vast and
varied empire an unrivaled and
unstoppable concentration of power this
is a man who is extraordinarily powerful
in commercial terms and in political
terms and in cultural terms
[Music]
he's on the level of purse certainly
the defining characteristic of this
thing that we call depressed baron it is
that constant
quest for more and more power and that's
what we'll remember murdock for and for
good and and
and bad